[موسيقى]
لذا
لذلك
[موسيقى]
استنادًا إلى المعلومات المتاحة حاليًا ، يبدو
أن حل مشكلات 5g هذه
سيكون طويلًا
وتدريجيًا على مدار أسابيع
وشهور
في هذه الأثناء ،
يتوقع الركاب والشاحنون حدوث تأخيرات وانقطاعات
حتى يتم حل المشكلات بالكامل
[موسيقى]
يكون نطاق التردد الذي تستخدمه 5g
مشابهًا جدًا لنطاق التردد الذي
تستخدمه أجهزة قياس الارتفاع بالرادار
وهناك احتمال وجود
تداخل أو إشارات خاطئة
مع 5g
في  مقياس الارتفاع الراداري حتى
تتمكن من الاعتماد عليه مع
مقياس الارتفاع الرادار الذي يمنحك ارتفاعًا معينًا
فوق الأرض ، فقد يكون خاطئًا
بناءً على التداخل مع 5g
[موسيقى]
هدفنا بالطبع هو الوصول إلى
حل حول نشر 5g والذي
يحافظ على أعلى مستوى من الأمان
مع تقليل الاضطرابات التي
تصيب سفر الركاب ، وهذا ما
نعمل على تحقيقه
[موسيقى]